[Music]
Adam
James
[Music]
Tina
Sara
[Music]
my name is wine and ap van Tilburg and I
work at King's College London in
psychology department one version
contained an author with no middle
initials the other versions had one two
four four middle initials instead and
what we found was that students liked
this written work better if the author
had more middle initials even though the
exact text of the of the essay was the
same this is something to do with the
stereotypes that people use so because
people with middle initials are seen as
more prestigious people automatically
but incorrectly assumed that their work
must therefore be of a higher standard
[Music]
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe and click the bail to receive
notifications for new videos see you
again soon